charmé le public c'est à la fois un
hommage personnel et artistique
véronique sanson monte sur scène pour
interpréter les grands succès de michel
berger elle sera sur la scène de
l'olympia à partir de demain et pour
trois semaines
thierry stampfler et georges mines angoy
vous font découvrir le spectacle en
avant première
ma mère
comme un retour aux sources il ya
presque trente ans véronique et michel
enfants des beaux quartiers parisiens
ont inventée ensemble une façon
singulière de faire sonner les mots
aujourd'hui véronique sanson redonne vie
au répertoire de michel berger
il était si proche que beaucoup
attribuent les chansons de l'un à
l'autre mais le public lui les
différents sites il oui c'est pour cent
sont d'abord puis ce sont michel berger
ils sont proches et soi même phrase et
je chantais quelqu'un qui est là actes
qu'elle a vachement mais en fin de
compte de ce que c'est ça
enfin je pense qu'elles veulent bâtir
des débats stands démonstrations sa
jolie entendrez
fiers de nous
de tous ces maux
ce qui reste c'est tout
je sais le
en
j'ai du mal à chanter quelque chose de
ses chansons j'ai du mal à définir
parce que j'ai moi même une émotion
parce que je pense je pense pas michel
je pense aux maux qui dit et que je
trouve magnifique et et quelquefois je
me dis mais faut-il absolument pas que
j'ai la gorge nouée parce que quand même
pour un chanteur
mais même avec ce répertoire nouveau le
public retrouvera ce curieux mélange de
fragilité d'énergie qui a toujours fait
le charme de véronique sanson
voilà